sí
bienvenidos de nuevo ahora ya sabemos
una fuerza neta está actuando sobre una
particular y si está acelerará en esta
dirección pero que tanto acelerará para
responder a la pregunta de cómo se
relacionan la fuerza y la aceleración
neutrón observó que si incrementamos la
fuerza neta por digamos 2 entonces la
aceleración aumenta por el mismo factor
esto quiere decir que la fuerza y la
aceleración son proporcionales entre sí
pero eso no es todo examinaremos ahora
la masa de nuestra particular imagina
que tenemos dos partículas que flotan en
el espacio las cuales tienen el mismo
tamaño pero diferentes masas como si una
fuera una pelota de ping pong y la otra
estuviera hecha de plomo si aplicamos la
misma fuerza como el viento a estas
partículas que sucedería
ambas partículas experimentarán la misma
fuerza neta en la dirección del viento
pero no acelerarán a la misma velocidad
la partícula con menor masa la pelota de
ping pong acelerará más rápido que la
partícula hecha de plomo así pues a
menor masa mayor aceleración y a mayor
masa menor aceleración lo que quiere
decir que la masa y la aceleración son
inversamente proporcionales entre sí y
ya sabemos que la aceleración es
proporcional a la fuerza si unimos todos
estos datos vemos que la aceleración
depende de la magnitud de la fuerza neta
la cual es proporcional a la aceleración
ya la masa del objeto la cual es
inversamente proporcional a la
aceleración esto nos dan que am es
proporcional a efe / / m y si
multiplicamos ambos lados por m
obtenemos que m veces a es proporcional
a
y si invertimos este resultado obtenemos
que f es proporcional a veces a newton
descubrió que f no es sólo proporcional
a m sino que de hecho es igual a m
esta es la segunda ley de newton
efe es igual a m
en resumen efe es la fuerza neta que
actúa sobre la particular m es la masa
de la particular y a es la aceleración
de la partícula
reflexionemos sobre la fuerza de la
gravedad tal vez hayas oído hablar
acerca del famoso experimento que
galileo llevó a cabo en 1589 en el cual
dejó caer dos pelotas desde la torre
inclinada de pisa una estaba hecha de un
material ligero y la otra de un material
pesado tal vez te sorprenda saber que
galileo observó que las dos pelotas
aceleraban exactamente la misma
velocidad esto sorprendió a todos en esa
época todo el mundo empezando por los
antiguos griegos simplemente suponían
que los objetos más pesados que hayan
más rápido que los objetos más ligeros
así que a diferencia del viento la
fuerza de la gravedad parece ser
independiente de la masa lo interesante
es preguntarnos por qué newton nos dio
la respuesta su primera ley de la
gravedad establece que los objetos con
mayor masa experimentan una fuerza
gravitacional más grande y su segunda
ley dice que la masa es una resistencia
a la aceleración estas dos tendencias
contrarias una que apoya la aceleración
y otra que se opone a ella se anulan
entre sí para entender matemáticamente
esto newton desarrolló la teoría de que
la fuerza debida a la gravedad llamada
aquí
efe mayúscula es proporcional a la masa
de la partícula f mayúscula es
proporcional a m
pensemos en la gravedad como un vector
de aceleración
llamémosle g de manera que f mayúscula
sea igual a mg
así pues tenemos dos ecuaciones la
segunda ley de newton a efe minúscula es
igual a m
donde f minúsculas la fuerza neta y la
ley de la gravedad de newton donde f
mayúscula es igual a mg
para una partícula que está la gravedad
la fuerza neta
efe minúscula es igual a efe mayúscula
está en minúscula es igual a mg que es
igual a et mayúscula que a su vez es
igual a m
para decirlo de manera más sencilla m g
es igual a m
ahora observa que las m se anulan con lo
que sólo quedan kg es igual a a
es decir la aceleración de una partícula
cuando solo la gravedad actúa sobre ella
es independiente de la masa de la
partícula esta es la razón por la que
objetos con distintas masas caen a la
misma velocidad una ecuación como ésta
que nos permite calcular la aceleración
de las partículas se denominan ecuación
de movimiento hemos cubierto muchos
conceptos nuevos e importantes en este
vídeo así que hagamos una pausa para que
practiques con el siguiente ejercicio